Thank you both.
If you've got a Bible, please turn with me to Matthew chapter 13.
It's also on the back of the worship guide or inside the worship guide.
Matthew chapter 13.
We will begin reading in verse 10.
We'll read down to verse 17 and then we'll skip a few verses and we'll pick it up once
again in verse 44 and read down to the end of verse 46.
It says, then the disciples came and said to him, that's Jesus, why do you speak to them
in parables?
And he answered them, to you it has been given to know the secrets of the kingdom of heaven,
but to them it has not been given.
For to the one who has more will be given, and he will have an abundance, but from the
one who has not, even what he has will be taken away.
This is why I speak to them in parables because seeing they do not see.
In hearing they do not hear, nor do they understand.
Indeed in their case the prophecy of Isaiah is fulfilled that says you will indeed hear,
but never understand, and you will indeed see, but never perceive.
For this people's heart has grown dull, and with their ears they can barely hear, and
their eyes they have closed, lest they should see with their eyes and hear with their
ears, and understand with their hearts and turn, and I would heal them.
But blessed are your eyes, for they see, and your ears for they hear.
For truly I say to you, many prophets and righteous people longed to see what you see, and did
not see it, and to hear what you hear, and did not hear it.
Verse 44.
The kingdom of heaven is like a treasure hidden in a field, which a man found and covered
up, then in his joy he goes and sells all that he has and buys that field.
Again, the kingdom of heaven is like a merchant in search of fine pearls, who on finding one
pearl of great value went and sold all that he had and bought it.
This is the word of the Lord.
Let's pray once again.
This is your word, and we are so grateful that you have spoken to us in your word.
Lord I pray that now by your Holy Spirit you would speak to us through your word.
Lord I pray that we would know you speaking to our hearts, and that you would help us
to respond in faith.
In Jesus' name we pray.
Amen.
Well, back in 2009, a man by the name of Terry Herbert took his metal detector to a field in
Staffordshire, England.
And it was one that he had purchased for two pounds and fifty cents to just convert what
it would have been at the time.
You're talking about like four dollars, something like that.
But it was good enough for his weekend hobby, this metal detector.
So he took it out in the fields like he did every weekend, but this one was
different because as he walked out in the field, all of a sudden the tone of the metal detector
started to change.
And so he realized he had come upon something.
And so the thing that he came upon would change his life forever because he stumbled
on what's now known as the Staffordshire Horde.
It was the largest discovery of Anglo-Saxon treasure that had ever been found.
There were 3,500 items of gold and silver that were collected up, and these were valued
at over five million US dollars.
Can you imagine the change that would have taken place there or how that would have felt
to have discovered that treasure?
Well this morning we're going to focus in on a story that Jesus told in Matthew 13,
verse 44.
It's about a man who discovered treasure, but it's a treasure of far greater worth than
any earthly treasure we might discover.
This is here in a series of parables that are being told by Jesus in Matthew chapter 13.
And parables, by the way, just to put it simply, are an earthly story with a heavenly
meaning.
And the short parable is there in verse 44.
Let's read it again.
He goes through a field, he finds treasure, he knows it's something big, he knows it's
going to be super valuable, but he can't just take it out of the field.
So he covers it up and he hatches a plan.
The plan is that if he goes and he buys that field, not only will the field be his, but
the treasure will rightfully be his as well.
By the way, that kind of five million dollar reward for the Staffordshire Horde had to be
split 50-50 between the actual land owner and the man who found it in the end.
So this guy in this text is not taking any chances.
He wants to make sure it is all his.
So if he's the rightful owner, he's the rightful owner of the treasure.
And the only way he could afford that field would be to sell everything that he has.
He doesn't have enough money to go and buy the field, but if he sells everything, he'll
have just enough to purchase it.
And the treasure is his.
Others might look on.
Imagine as he's liquidating everything, selling everything off.
People might think he's crazy.
You're selling all that to buy this field?
Like where are you going to live?
What are you going to do if all you have is a field?
Doesn't make sense to onlookers, but he knows what they do not know.
He's discovered treasure.
So what is Jesus saying here?
What is this parable about?
Well, he tells us what the parable is about.
It's about what all the parables in Matthew 13 are pointing towards.
It's about the kingdom of heaven.
It says the kingdom of heaven is like treasure.
So kingdom and kingship are major themes in the book of Matthew.
I mean, you see the kingdom repeated over and over again throughout it, but the
kingdom is especially seen in the arrival of the king himself.
Right?
You go right to the start of the book and you've got the genealogy of Jesus.
And to make sure that we know that this is Jesus, the son of David, right?
Because he's the heir to the throne of David.
That's what we need to know.
The wise men come looking for Jesus.
But who are they looking for?
We're looking for the one who was born king that we may go and worship him.
When Jesus starts his ministry, he's saying, repent for the kingdom of heaven is at hand.
Then at the very end of the book of Matthew, Jesus, before he ascends says, all authority
in heaven and on earth has been given to me.
In other words, he's the king who reigns over all things.
So he's teaching us here about the nature of this kingdom over which he is king.
And each of these parables are telling us something different about the kingdom.
So what is this story in particular that we're focusing in on telling us about Christ's kingdom?
Here's what it's telling us.
It's telling us about the worth or the value of that kingdom.
And it's telling us how the worth or the value of that kingdom is seen in the lives
of those who discover it.
So we're looking at essentially it's worth and it's effect on those who see it's worth,
see it's value.
So that's what we're going to look at just in our time together now.
So let's look at the worth of the kingdom, first of all.
The worth of the kingdom is portrayed through this picture of treasure.
Now to broaden our lens out a little bit, like the kingdom, so treasure is repeated throughout
the the gospel of Matthew.
Treasure is mentioned in Matthew more than any other book in the New Testament.
And the first time the word treasure is used is when the wise men are bringing
their treasures to Jesus.
I couldn't help but remember being at a carol service, a bit like we had last week
where someone had had a reading and they came up and the very thing that they did not
want to do happened.
They were reading about the wise men and they came to the bed about they brought
their treasures and they read it slowly and deliberately, but still the thing
that they didn't want to do happened.
You can imagine what happened.
They said they came bringing gold, Frankenstein and myrrh.
And then they carried on with it.
So they bring gold, frankincense and myrrh.
But what are they communicating by bringing this offering?
Well, there's a lot we could look into there, but let's just see the big picture here.
Remember, they're coming seeking the one who is born king and they say,
we're coming because we want to worship him.
That's in Matthew 2, 2.
When they come into the house, that's exactly what they're doing.
They're worshiping him in the one of the ways they're worshiping him is
by presenting these treasures.
They're not giving these gifts.
Like you don't give gifts to a king to meet the king's needs.
It's not that he's lacking something.
So your gift is helping out a little bit.
You give gift to a king to honor the king.
So there's, as they're presenting their gifts, their treasures, they're saying,
you are worthy.
This is showing your worthiness.
They are honoring the king.
They are worshiping him, ascribing worth.
It's saying that he is more valuable to them than their riches.
And this is the kind of thing we are seeing about the worth of the kingdom in this parable.
Here's what it's telling us about the kingdom of God is that the kingdom of God,
the worth of the kingdom of God is supreme.
It is superior to all else.
And it's supreme worth is seen in the man's willingness to sell everything that he might get it.
So the kingdom is so valuable that it's worth leaving everything for.
So we might think, well, okay, it's so valuable, it's worth leaving everything behind if you were to have that kingdom.
What's so valuable about it?
One's that it lasts forever.
Earlier in the book of Matthew, Jesus talked about the fleeting nature of our earthly treasures.
They don't last, so we ought to lay up treasure in heaven because that lasts forever.
But there's something greater that shows the supremacy of the treasure that is the kingdom of heaven.
It's supreme because it is given to us in Christ.
So here's the deal.
Jesus himself is the ultimate treasure, who is so valuable that he is worth leaving everything for.
He came preaching the kingdom of heaven is at hand because the king had arrived.
The king was at hand.
He is the one who is supremely valuable.
And all the good that we experience in the kingdom of God, in the kingdom of heaven,
is given to us in and through him.
So he is the one who is of ultimate worth.
So we worship him.
This is what Paul is talking about in Philippians chapter three.
He lists out all of his accolades, all of the things that people used to really look up
to him for and respect him for before he knew Christ.
He was a respected religious leader in his community with everything that you could want,
humanly speaking.
But now that same community is despising him and attacking him on so many different fronts.
And as he writes the book of Philippians, he is even in prison.
But it doesn't want anybody to feel sorry for him.
Here's what he says.
He says in Philippians three, verses seven and eight, thinking about his past.
He says, whatever gain I had, I counted as a loss for the sake of Christ.
Indeed, I count everything as loss because of the surpassing worth of knowing Christ
Jesus my Lord.
For his sake, I have suffered the loss of all things and count them as rubbish in
order that I may gain Christ.
So take all the things that people live for, possessions, experiences, accolades, everything
else.
Just pile it all up.
Put it on one side of the scales.
And then put Christ on the other side of the scales.
It flings those other things out into eternity because the weight of the worthiness of
Christ is far greater, incomparable to anything else in this world.
There is no comparison with the worth of Christ and his kingdom.
So we might look at this and say, well, why doesn't everybody then treasure Christ?
Like if he's supremely valuable, why does so many people not even see that at all?
Jesus speaks to that here.
He says the kingdom of heaven is like a treasure hidden in a field.
It's hidden.
This time of year, I remember when I was a kid, any kids in here don't take my,
don't follow my example in this.
I remember this was the time of year when I used to sneak around the house looking in
closets, looking where I thought if my parents were to hide a gift somewhere, where would they
hide it looking around everywhere?
I knew a gift was there, but I knew it was hidden.
So I had to try to find it.
And then Christmas morning came, of course, and you had to pretend to be surprised.
Oh, wow.
Thank you so much.
So the kingdom of Christ and the King himself is kind of hidden from view here.
The nativity, for example, is one place where we might look at his hiddenness.
He is Emmanuel.
He is God himself with us, and yet he is veiled in flesh, arriving as a vulnerable baby.
He was born king, the one who has all authority over everything, but he wasn't born in a palace.
Where's he laid?
He is laid in a humble manger.
When the wise men came to see him, like if you, I mean, imagine that they're worshiping
this baby, onlookers would think they've lost it.
What are they doing worshipping this baby from this family who's from Nazareth?
Jesus is glorious, and yet throughout his ministry, the vast majority of his ministry, that glory
is concealed from view.
And yet there were people who were willing to leave everything to follow him.
And many of those first followers would literally leave everything in the sense that they
would be killed.
They would be martyred for their faith in Christ.
They were willing to say, now, I'll sell everything.
I'll leave everything behind because Jesus is worth it.
He's better than life itself.
So how do we come to see Christ in this way?
How do we see his kingdom as a treasure?
Well, the answer is given in Jesus' statement to his disciples back in verse 11.
We won't delve into all of that, but you see Jesus is speaking about the purpose of parables.
And this is why I think the hiddenness is kind of calling back to what Jesus said before.
But just see verse 11.
Jesus is speaking to his disciples, his followers, those who've left everything to follow
him.
To you it has been, note this word, given to know the secrets of the kingdom of heaven.
But to them, those who are not seeing, it has not been given.
So if you see Jesus as this all-surpassing treasure, if you see him as the one who's worth leaving
everything for, if your heart leaps at the thought of being with him, it's not because
you're more clever than other people around you who don't see that.
It's because God has given you eyes to see that.
He gives us that gift of seeing Jesus as this all-surpassing treasure.
It is a blessing to see Jesus in this way.
This is as true for us as it was for them.
Life in God's kingdom is a gift.
And that includes receiving the life in that kingdom.
That even the receiving is a gift, and all the glory goes to God.
So you see that scripture, salvation is presented as a gift.
Or by grace you've been saved through faith.
That none of ourselves.
It is the gift of God, not of works lest anyone should boast.
That's Ephesians 2, 8, and 9.
Then you see like a Philippians 1, 29.
And there it speaks about our faith as being a gift from God.
So God is the one who's praised when we see Christ as our all-surpassing treasure.
He's the one who's of supreme worth.
We should see him in that way.
And as we see him, we say praise God for this wonderful gift you've given us in Christ.
So that's the worth of the kingdom.
But secondly, see this.
The effect of the kingdom.
So the worth is kind of looking outside ourselves to its value.
And now we're looking a bit more in our own direction, seeing what effect does it
have on us when we see it as a treasure that it is.
Well, what effect did it have on this man?
Second half of the verse.
In his joy he goes and sells all that he has and buys that field.
So you've got a two-fold effect here.
You've got joy and you've got selling all.
So you see his delight in the treasure and you see his decision to sell everything in
light of this treasure he's seen.
They show us what it means to, or the kind of effect having a true vision of Christ
as the treasure that he is.
All right, so let's look at those.
So joy, so he delights in the kingdom.
So when it comes to the kingdom of heaven, it would not be wrong to speak of it in terms
of obligation or duty.
So if you're a U.S. citizen, there are certain legal and civic duties that come with that,
like obeying laws, paying taxes, jury duty.
Now everybody loves that.
Voting, things like that.
That kind of comes with the package.
So when we're thinking about Christ as king and the reign of his kingdom over all things,
it's true to say we ought to submit to his authority.
Absolutely true.
We ought to follow his commands.
It is our duty whether we feel like it or not.
That's true.
But that's not the emphasis here.
Here we see that the kingdom isn't just something that we ought to receive.
It is something that if we truly see it for what it is, we will want to receive.
We will want Christ to be our king, we'll want to live in his kingdom.
So the emphasis here is not on duty but on delight.
This man's decision to sell everything isn't motivated by obligation.
Like, I've got to sell everything in order to get that field.
He is motivated not by obligation, but joy.
He wants to do this because he knows what's in that field is far greater than anything he's
leaving behind.
So it's his heart that's driving him.
He wants to do this.
This is what happens when we experience Christ's kingdom for what it truly is.
It isn't something that we want to, that we kind of begrudgingly go along with.
We live in light of who he is because we want.
We follow Christ because we want him.
We live in his kingdom because we want to because we know it's so much better.
Jesus is so good that we know he's worth leaving all for.
So we do it gladly.
A couple hundred years ago there was a Scottish preacher by the name of Thomas Chalmers who
preached a sermon and its ripple effects are still being felt to this day.
And specifically the title of the sermon just kind of gets lodged in your brain and
it's this.
The expulsive power of a new affection.
It's kind of getting at what this verse is getting at in many ways.
He makes the case in that sermon that our sinful desires and worldly pursuits aren't
done away with simply by saying you ought to rid yourselves of those things.
Those are bad.
Get rid of them.
Stop doing them.
Now that's true.
He says but that's not really what changes us.
What changes us is an expulsive power of a new affection.
We let go of those things when something far greater is offered to us.
So we let go of our sinful desires and our worldly pursuits.
With those open hands we receive a treasure that is far greater than those things.
And so when it comes to following Christ becoming a Christian right at the start of
your journey.
We let go of those things and we receive Christ.
When it comes to our ongoing fight against sin it isn't just this is wrong ought to stop
doing this and just focusing on it in that way.
It's seeing Christ for who he is and saying he is so much better and what I have in him
is so much better and it's in looking to him that we're given the power to let
go of those things in order to receive that which is far greater.
We've got a dog at home.
I don't know about your dog if you've got one but sometimes we get something in his
mouth and he just will not let it go.
It could be a sock or something like that.
And I could try my best to get the sock out and tell him if he gets in his mind he's
going to have that.
So what do you do in that instance?
Do you just keep yanking or do you get a little piece of chicken or something like
that.
As soon as you have something better all of a sudden the jaw slackens a little
bit.
It's like actually that chicken is much better than this sock here.
So this is the idea.
So what makes our hearts leap to where we let go of those lesser things.
It is the joy that we have in Jesus.
So yeah Jesus calls us to leave behind of self rule for following him and a life in
his kingdom where he's in charge.
Here we see that that is so much more desirable and satisfying than anything that would keep
us back from him.
It's like what we see in Psalm 1611.
It says, you make me to know the path of life.
So yes the Lord shows us the way we should go and tells us what that path is like or
who's on that path or where that path leads.
It says, in your presence there is fullness of joy and at your right hand are pleasures
forevermore.
Another place where we see joy in Jesus shining brightly is when Jesus arrived and the glory
of the Lord shone like treasure in a field where shepherds were keeping over their watch
over their flocks by night.
And the angels brought them good news as that glory was shining.
What was their good news?
I bring you good news of great joy which is for all people.
So it's said at the start of our service that the kind of theme for this Sunday of the Advent
season is joy.
And joy is something that we all desire.
I hope we're seeing here that joy is something that we often look for in all the wrong places.
We look for it in the things that our eyes can see.
And then when we have some temporary happiness in that thing but then when it's kind
of luster, say diminishes or that thing is removed, all of a sudden we're in a really
bad place because our joy goes with that thing.
Because our joy is not rooted in the eternal treasure that is Jesus that nothing can take
away.
It's not wrong to enjoy those things.
We enjoy those things for his sake knowing that he is our ultimate joy.
Where we feel that joy or not, our eyes are drawn to him because we know that it's in him
that there's fullness of joy.
And one day we'll be with him and at his right hand there are pleasures forever more.
This is how we can say with Paul that there are days when we are 2 Corinthians 6, 10
sorrowful, yet always rejoicing.
That's something I can resonate with.
There's a sorrow that's there but I know that my joy is secure in Jesus and I'll keep
looking to him knowing that he will satisfy that longing.
There's a source of joy that nothing can take away.
We'll leave everything because we know that we have that and that lasts forever.
It's given to us in Jesus.
Earlier we looked at how God is the one who enables us to see and to savor Jesus
for who he truly is.
But you know that also includes our joy in him.
Joy is spoken of as a fruit of the Spirit.
At the end of our service we're going to have a closing benediction, which I'll go
ahead and read now just so you see why we've chosen that for today.
And it's Romans 15, 13.
It says, May the God of hope fill you with all joy and peace.
So God is the one who fills his people with joy.
But then it tells us how he does it.
I don't know why I'm a bit cheap but I want that.
So God, yes, give me this joy.
So may the God of hope fill you with joy and that it ends with these two words.
In believing.
So God gives his people joy as they look to him by faith to receive it
knowing that it is only found in him.
It's our job to look to the Lord knowing that he is the giver of joy.
Joy is found in believing.
So if you long for joy, look to Jesus and keep on looking
because he is the eternal fountain of joy.
One final thing.
And that's that.
Okay, so you see that reaction, that effect of delight.
But you also see this decision to sell everything.
What do we make of that?
We've seen a couple things already which will not kind of rehash.
But in the decision to sell everything we see, not only the presence of joy
but the proof of that joy and practical steps that were taken.
Our delight is seen in the decisions that we make.
No, if you see, okay, he sells everything that he has.
One misunderstanding might be, oh, okay, well, I guess we can buy our way into heaven.
Maybe it's something that could be purchased.
We'll just know that that is not true financially and it's not true in terms of our good works.
Either we cannot buy our way into God's presence or His favor.
Our place with the Lord was purchased by Christ.
And really you see this pointing to him in ways too because Christ desires us.
You may even feel some hesitancy to say this but it's even true to say that He treasures us as well.
Throughout Scripture, God, you know, Deuteronomy chapter 7, God views His people as His treasured possession.
He promises His people in Zephaniah 3.17 that He would rejoice over them with gladness
and exult over them with loud singing.
So He treasures His people. He rejoices over them with singing.
So when He looks at us, we might think, well, if He looks at me, here's all my sinfulness
and all of my mistakes or whatever.
Is He going to rejoice over me?
Well, know this, Jesus saw our sinfulness.
But He also saw the coming glory.
He saw that He was going to give us His righteousness.
Jesus came and He purchased our redemption on the cross.
He paid for us to make us His own.
And so we are treasured, sung over, rejoiced in, in Christ.
It even says it this way.
It doesn't just desire us. He dies for us.
And it says it this way.
Hebrews chapter 12 and verse 2.
Jesus, who for the joy that was set before Him, endured the cross.
So He gave all in joy to make us His treasured possession.
Think of it.
So if you have your know this relationship with Jesus
and you have your eyes set on eternity with Him,
let's go back to this point.
This will be seen in the decisions that you make.
So what we value is seeing in how we spend our time, our energy, our money.
Jesus said this in Matthew 621,
where your treasure is, there your heart will be also.
So what we treasure is seen and what we do with our treasure.
The way we use our resources is an indication of where our hearts are.
A couple of examples of this.
One's a negative, the other's a positive.
Think of the rich young ruler.
He came, he was thinking about following Jesus,
but Jesus could see his heart and Jesus says to him,
there's one thing that you're lacking.
Sell everything that you have and give it to the poor
and then you come and follow me.
Jesus wasn't telling all of us that all of us have to sell everything
that we have to follow Him, but he knew that that was what was
in the seat of the rich young ruler's heart.
We're told that the rich young ruler walked away,
not joyfully, ready to sell all.
He walked away with sorrow because he had many possessions.
So his unwillingness to let go of it showed
that he really wasn't wanting to follow Jesus
because he was holding on to those things instead.
All right, positive example.
2 Corinthians chapter eight.
The apostle Paul is going around and he's taking up a collection
for Christians who are suffering with poverty in Judea.
And he's about to go to the church at Corinth
and receive money from them as well.
He says, let me give you an example
of what I've seen recently.
It's the church of, the churches in Macedonia,
they were also struggling with poverty as well.
He said, but they insisted that they take part
in this collection that was being taken up
for the believers in Judea.
And he says, here's why that they insisted
that they take part in giving to others as well.
He says it was because of their overflowing joy.
And then he goes on in 2 Corinthians chapter nine
saying that we, this is a grace
that should be true of all of us.
We're all called to be cheerful givers.
So there's a principle that's there in the New Testament
that we are called to be a giving people
as followers of Christ.
But we're not giving from a place of obligation
but out of a heart of joy.
We do it gladly because our treasure is in heaven.
We know that the Lord can use that
for his good purposes in the world.
So we do it cheerfully.
Now I don't know what the specifics of that
will look like for you, but let me just say
it would be good for all of us to prayerfully consider
like Lord, what would you have me to do
in this area of my life?
When it comes to that area,
we're giving of ourselves in other areas too.
We do it because of the treasure that we see in Jesus.
I don't think Terry Herbert regretted
spending two pounds and 50 pence for dollars
on that metal detector.
Once he had received the treasure,
it was like nothing in comparison.
You know, when we see Christ for who he truly is,
we gladly surrender the whole of ourselves to him
because he's far greater than we can imagine.
So as we're moving to communion to now,
now I wanna ask you what are you treasuring?
We're gonna pray together,
but as you come to the Lord in prayer,
just ask yourself the question, what has my heart?
What am I looking to to satisfy the longings of my heart?
Take some time looking to Christ,
praying that you might know him as your treasure,
that you might delight in him.
Hear these words about what Jesus did for us.
Second Corinthians eight, once again, it says,
for you know the grace of our Lord Jesus Christ,
that though he was rich, yet for your sake,
he became poor that through your poverty,
or by his poverty, you might become rich.
So Jesus took on the poverty of our state.
He took on our humanity, our sin, and our death.
He willingly surrendered his life on the cross
and this bread is symbolically reminding us
of what he did on the cross
because there on the cross, his body was broken for us.
And as we partake in the bread,
we're reminding ourselves,
remembering what he has done for us on the cross.
Not only was his body broken on the cross,
his blood was shed on the cross.
And as we drink of this cup,
we are reminded of his blood that was shed for us
upon the cross.
So we surrender our lives to him
because he first surrendered his life for us.
We treasure him because he decided to make us his own
by dying in our place and rising again.
So before we come to the table, let's pray together.
Let's take a moment and quiet prayer
and then I'll pray and give thanks for the bread and wine.